allawis yukon herzlich willkommen hier
heute mal den lieben zuschauer zu einer
weiteren episode von whatsapp fällt mit
luca das was wirklich komplett freuen
ich würde sagen gefahren direkt mit dem
ersten teil und zwar schreibt jemand
seinem kollegen braunen fettes im
display daraufhin antwortet sein kollege
dann auch direkt sind mal screenshot ja
da muss ich wirklich sagen du auf einer
rolltreppe wäre es dummheit am laufenden
band als nächstes fragt ihr jemand
seinen kumpel bruder bist du bekifft
daraufhin antwortet sein kollege bist du
ja der studie erklärt mir gerade die weg
zum weihnachtsmann
du bist nicht so eine richtige evolution
bremse alter wir fragt jemand seine
freundin schatz liebst du mich und seine
freundin antwortet einfach wie der
tunnel melli spätere schlechte
verbindung funktioniert auf jeden fall
auch bei roger schatz ich liege gerade
in deiner kacke und es riecht so schön
nach dir kakerlake verdammt
autokorrektur hier schreibt nun ein
mädchen ihrer freundin manchmal schäme
ich mich für meinen freund sie antwortet
darauf hin warum jetzt schon wieder und
daraufhin antwortet die dame wieder er
hat gerade tatsächlich das wasser im
topf umgerührt damit es nicht anbrennt
ich habe das gefühl dass ich durch die
reaktion hier auch dümmer werde unser
bild hat schon zwei likes der eine last
von mir der andere von mir an sinn und
wieder ist so ein scheiß wieder ruhig
durch klatschen durch mein zimmer laufen
allerdings direkt weiter mit der
nächsten intelligenzbestien zwar
schreibt jemand starb die andere person
antwortete daraufhin dein ernst den
imperativ mit idigi nils und daraufhin
antwortet die personen dann wieder
sterbe ich würd mir am liebsten eine
kreissäge durch mein gehirn rahmen wir
nun allerdings in dieser folge das erste
mal zu einem etwas längeren cut verlauf
und verschreckte jemand was machst du so
im bett liegen und mein müsli essen
daraufhin schreibt die andere person
wieder cool was würdest du machen wenn
ich neben dir liegt würde man löst die
essen und wenn du kein müsli hättest in
die küche gehen und mir müsli holen also
ich muss echt mal aufhören zu klatschen
alter das wollen wir auf jeden fall
einen court aufnimmt ganz ganz ganz ganz
hohem niveau wo man allerdings gerade
bei niveau sind aber gott was für eine
überleitung darüber direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten intelligenten wesen und
zwar schreibt er ich musste heute im
tutorium furzen und das no shit ist eine
ganz ganz schlimme situation also erst
mal ganz kurz was ein tutorium überhaupt
ist das ist so eine art kurs den mann
mit seinen kommilitonen als mit seinen
mitstudenten hat und einigen dozenten
was über die uni hochschule hinaus geht
also über die module hinaus rutsche
direkt wieder meine universitäts
zeitreihen auf jeden fall ist es dort
relativ ruhig man hört kein laut man
traut sich sogar meistens nicht mal
irgendwie zu husten aber ist ja auch
egal nur für euch jetzt erst mal das zum
verständnis was überhaupt ein tutorium
ist er schreibt auf jeden fall weiter
kam auf die geniale idee meinen lehrbuch
auf den boden fallen zu lassen und
gleichzeitig zu furzen an sich ist die
idee nachweis einen furz dadurch von dem
knall des buches übertönt wird
allerdings schreibt er dann lasse also
mein buch fallen alle gucken mich an und
ich furze laut dein niveau hat wirklich
noch im keller höhenangst allerdings nun
wieder zu einem autokorrektur fail und
verschreibt jemand hey süße bewegst du
deinen elefanten körper heute zu mir
elegant elegant und seine art keine
ahnung
wer kennt sie nicht die autokorrektur
was ist ein anderer begriff für kfz
mechaniker autokorrektur
[Gelächter]
den hab ich mich ausgelacht
verbot umgehen ich bin hungrig heinrich
ich bin etwa das ist nicht lustig ich
bin ernsthaft nein du bist hungrig du
bist unlustig nein ich bin dead
gibt es auch
hier schreibt
seinem kumpel ich bin mal gespannt wer
alles meinen geburtstag vergisst wieso
wann hast du denn geburtstag heute ja
das ist mir noch nie passiert jetzt gibt
einfach nichts schlimmeres wie wenn man
den kollegen in der schule wieder an der
uni und dann erfährt man ihm eine stunde
später wie jemand anderes ihm gratuliert
das ist mir wie gesagt noch nie passiert
warum sagst du immer ich bin fett weil
du fit bist weißt du wie ich mich dabei
fühle
rumrich ja
nicht ob ich diese whatsapp chat fels
witzig
oder fremdschämt finde allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten feld und zwar
bekommt die immer die nachrichte wie alt
ist deine freundin daraufhin antwortet
er 46 jahre person schreibt wieder dein
ernst die könnte deine mutter sein jahr
dicker aber sie ist deine mutter das war
ein richtig richtig geiler kontakt
konnte man über hannover 96 in dieser
saison nie sagen
[Gelächter]
rcs bekommt hier einen typen nachricht
von seiner freundin und verschreibt sie
schatz wieso können wir nicht zu süß
sein und dann ein foto von einem pärchen
wie sie sich umarmen und küssen und
total süß aussehen der junge antwortet
daraufhin seiner freundin war hässlich
sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja ich auch als nächstes schreibt ja
eine person seiner mutter nahm ich habe
aus versehen cola verschüttet und dabei
bin ich ausgerutscht und hat mir das
bein gebrochen ich liege im krankenhaus
und die mutter antwortet darauf hin
liest cola auf dem teppich gekommen das
ist so eine richtige männer nachricht du
hast dabei hingeflogen teppich highlight
machen war allerdings direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten whatsapp verschreibt sie
jemand hey süße also wahrscheinlich ein
typ an seine freundin daraufhin schreibt
das mädel warum süße weil du es bist und
jetzt kombiniert das mädel und rechnet
eins und eins zusammen süß honig
honigbiene biene blume blume blütchen
blümchen benjamin blümchen benjamin
blümchen elefanten elefanten ist die
türen durch die darfst du dich gerne
raus bewegen nun kommen wir zu einem
whatsapp fall den ich wirklich gesehen
habe und mit wirklich gedacht habe denke
das ist eine richtig geile idee ich
werde ihm eine liebe einfach am ersten
april gestehen und wenn er mich nicht
will spring ich im kreis und sag einfach
april april
als nächste schreibt ihr jetzt eine
junge einem mädchen in einer beziehung
ist eine whatsapp nachricht und fragte
ja was habe ich nicht was dein freund
hat und daraufhin antwortet das mädel
die in einer beziehung ist eine freundin
also das ist wirklich fast noch ein
krasser rates als denen wir zu beginn
hatten allerdings kommen wir jetzt mal
wieder zu einem etwas längeren cut
verlauf und zwar fragte jemand wirst du
gerade steine an meinem fenster ja fragt
euch einfach nicht an der person im chat
antwortet auf jeden fall habe daraufhin
fragt der typ wieder wozu gibt es denn
handys oder du hast recht und dann denkt
jetzt okay dann schreibt ihm halt hey
ich bin da kommt man nach draußen hast
du gerade ernsthaft dein handy gegen
meine scheibe geworfen
als gott die intelligenz verteilt hast
was du auch glaube ich einfach gerade
auf dem klo hat schreibt hier ein
mädchen ihrer freundin habe die
fernbeziehung nicht mehr ausgehalten
habe ihn dann endgültig neben meinem
bett gestellt daraufhin fragt sich das
mädel mit dem sie schreibt von wem
redest du meinem kühlschrank wie single
kann man eigentlich sein apropos single
mich wird es mega interessieren ob ihr
in einer beziehung sein
oder single weil ich glaube die meisten
zuschauer von mir sind noch unter 18 und
bei uns was so unter 18 waren so circa
90 single und mich wird es einfach mal
interessieren jetzt gerade ist also
stimmt hier gern mal oben up oder
schreibt ihr und in die kommentare das
wird mich einfach einfach nur aus
interesse wollen wir allerdings nur noch
schon zum letzten wort fällt für heute
meine damen und herren und zwar ist es
wirklich ein whatsapp chat verlauf fälle
wo ich mir einfach denke das ist eins zu
eins luca und zwar bekommt jemand eine
nachricht um 17 uhr 22 pro wollen wir
uns treffen er antwortete daraufhin ja
können wir machen ja ich bin in fünf
minuten bei dir also eigentlich um 17
uhr 27 dementsprechend um 19 58 also
mehr als zweieinhalb stunden später
kommt dann die nachricht dicker wo
bleibst du alter machst du eine
welttournee
sorry die gab ihm gerade aus dem haus
raus gibt noch fünf minuten alles wieder
okay du wolltest du eigentlich schon vor
mehr als zweieinhalb stunden da sein
aber in ordnung ok fünf minuten wäre ja
dann 20 uhr 3 oder so die nächste
nachricht von der anderen person kommt
um 7 uhr am nächsten morgen junge
bleibst und er antwortet 45 minuten
später
binnen fünf minuten da abu suhri das ist
eins zu eins ich allerdings kann ich da
nur sagen os late but the wait das
heutige bietet allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch diese
zweite episode wie so zeitig eine 4 wenn
euch diese zweite episode % fails mit
luca also meiner hässlichen wenigkeit
wenn euch das video heute gefallen hat
dann lass unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter dem video hier da und schreibt mir
auch und in die kommentare
ob ihr in einer woche einen dritten teil
haben wollt das war's abonniert main
kanal wollte ich noch sagen weil ich
sehe dass voll viele immer meine videos
anschauen die gar nicht abonnent sind
mir einfach warum weil es kostenlos ihr
verpasst keine videos mehr und jetzt
kommt aber dann auch das auto
[Musik]